indeed
we have variety assessments on a number
of issues
but both sides expressed their intention
to understand each other and to seek
common ground talks were quite
constructive
as for cyber security we agreed that
we would begin consultations in this
respect
i believe it is extremely important with
regards to
return of ambassadors to their
workplaces
return of american ambassador to moscow
and our ambassador to
washington we agreed that they would
return to their
service to their duties and
a citizen that you have mentioned
first this person knew full well that he
violates
the law that exists in russia and he
had to understand that he is a person
that
is a repeated offender he ignored
the requirement of the law
and he knew full well that he is wanted
nevertheless he came back to russia and
he deliberately
wanted to be arrested
i don't think he's looking for a cold
war with the united states
i don't think it's about a as i said to
him i said your generation of mine are
about 10 years apart
this is not a kumbaya moment as you used
to say back in the 60s in the united
states like
let's hug and love each other but it's
clearly not in anybody's interest
your country's not mine for us to be in
a situation where we're
in a new cold war and i truly believe
he thinks that he understands that but
that does not mean he's ready to quote
figured legend lay down his arms and say
come on he still i believe is concerned
about
being quote encircled